il ya trop de d'hommes politiques qui
jouent avec la sphère des retraites et
qui font miroiter des réformes
formidable alors par exemple les pôles à
ce qu'on appelle les retraites par
points le système de retraite parfois
j'y suis favorable mais il faut pas
faire croire aux français que ça va
régler le problème des retraites
le système par points en réalité ça
permet une chose qu'aucun homme
politique n'a vous ça permet de baisser
chaque année le montant des points la
valeur des points et donc de diminuer le
niveau des pensions
de la même façon il ya des hommes
politiques qui explique en fusion enfin
en fusionnant les régimes de retraite en
faisant en sorte que public privé soit
au même niveau on va combler les
déficits des régimes de retraite c'est
totalement fou il faut le faire pour des
raisons de justice sociale mais faire
croire parce que c'est évidemment très
confortable de dire au secteur privé
regardez si le secteur public paient des
cotisations même niveau que vous et si
les âges de départ en retraite et
équivalents et c'est vos régimes de
retraite serait équilibré c'est
complètement fausses et arithmétiquement
faux